one of the very first experiments that
tainted in my doctorate it was involved
ruthenium and so let me just show you my
PhD thesis up here ruthenium is a metal
that is somewhat like iron and it comes
from ruthenium or was first discovered
in ruthenia which is an area I've
checked what is now the Czech Republic
and so it is another element that has
its name from an area a geographical
location so this is a sample of
ruthenium sponge so the ruthenium metal
has been precipitated to form a very
fine particles so here we'll just open
the box and so I'm not going to show you
all the all my thesis because it would
be boring the ruthenium is a very very
reactive metal especially when it's
formed in this very fine sponge type
material the various wiggly lines on
here tell me something about the
structure of this molecule and I got
really excited you can imagine that was
just finished my first degree at
University and this was an element that
was really country and can still
remember the orange color and this is
because all of the gases in the air
particularly oxygen and hydrogen
adsorbed to it and then participate in
reactions like oxidation or reduction so
the ruthenium is very very finely
divided and if I dip it you can see in
the bottom of the vial very fine powders
but again because of the particle size
this is really dark very black very nice
sample everything and very useful for
for catalytic chemistry this is my PhD
thesis that's my doctoral thesis if
you'd like a summary of the work that
I've done and if you look up here behind
me you can see the these black volumes
up here are the ones which my students
have done in years to come this to 2008
ones here at the end
and the reason for this is that in order
to be a qualified chemist just like when
somebody is learning to fly an aeroplane
they have to do a bit of flying just by
themselves to make sure they're safe
before they fly an airliner so in the
same way that chemists when they're
learning to be professional chemists
once they've done their first degree
have to do some experiments themselves
to discover new things just to make sure
that they can handle things safely and
really enjoy the excitement of the
subject so that can then communicate it
to others